high breath none of that matters you
know what i mean
and that's just my personal opinion but
don't none of that matter nobody cares
about your plight only you
care about your plight and only you'll
ever be able to care about it in the
capacity that
you you know ever gonna be able to make
any real change
about it so for me i understand that
there's no way for me to be able to be
successful if i'm not basing
the success off of what i believe
success is
not what the society believes success is
or what
the person next to me believes success
is i have to establish my own
success so therefore i can relish in the
things that mean something to me
and that'll carry you throughout
the cloud of you know comparing yourself
to people or
not getting that opportunity or getting
told no and all of that all of that
you know doesn't matter because once you
establish your successes it doesn't
matter if anybody else looks at your
success
and says it's not where it's supposed to
be so is that something you would
recommend comics do
starting out is establish what success
is yes
yes definitely establish what you want
and don't
make it vague oh i want to be the next
kevin hart
i want to be the next bill birl i want
to be the there's already a kevin hart
and bill burr
so how are you going to do what you need
to do to become the first you
you know what i mean and it doesn't have
to look the way that people say it looks
you know i live in north carolina to
this day i went to
college in winston-salem north carolina
and i still live there
when i graduated college i didn't want
to go
back to dc because i knew once i
established that i was going to do this
for a living
once you start to hit those pitfalls
it's a little different when people that
know you
are inquiring about your you know
well-being you know if a stranger says
oh you ain't you shouldn't be doing
this
okay but when your mom is like baby
what's going on you know it's not coming
from a place of malice you're really
concerned about
your well-being so therefore you have to
make sure that
well at least i had to make sure that i
didn't allow that to affect me because i
didn't know how it would because i never
dealt with that before but i have dealt
with
you know my mom influence on me
and i know they're not just using her as
an example just because that's
probably the the biggest opinion that i
accept in my life as far as somebody
who's
who knows me i've never felt or
experienced what it felt like to have
her see me
fail in a manner where there was nothing
to fall back on but my own merit if i
failed at school
it was you know a curriculum that wasn't
being followed
if i failed at sports it was a
curriculum that wasn't being followed
when it comes to making your dreams come
true there is no curriculum
you know i mean there's no blueprint so
you have to create it i'm creating a
blueprint for
me and my family name you know so i i
didn't know how i would deal with my mom
seeing me
you know catch them else that you catch
doing this as a you know career
and looking and like you know babe you
don't have to go through this you good
enough to do anything do something else
so i stayed where i didn't know anybody
and had to make it work and it's
you know north carolina's not a hotbed
of talent nobody's really
coming there to look for talent there's
plenty of talent there just like it's
plenty of talent everywhere but
it doesn't have the name of a new york
or la
atlanta so if you can make a name for
yourself in that space
then you're doing something so that's
the way i challenge myself and i still
live there now because
it provides a level of peace of mind to
me that i can't find anywhere
else and i'm totally fine with that
being the case
when you establish your success do you
like do you have it written down
somewhere or how clear is the vision
i mean i i started out writing
five-point plans for myself
right this is just something i learned
from just coming from the community that
i came from and the
guys that influenced me growing up i
would
five years five points and i can't move
from one to two until i complete one
you know i mean so i started in 08
and supposedly i gave myself five years
to complete these things
and now i'm on what you know i've been
doing this coming up on 11 years in
august and i'm on what my fourth
five-year plan because i've accomplished
the things that i wanted to accomplish
well that many times already
so it's like i challenge myself
every day you know every single day that
i wake up i
challenge myself to become a better
version of me
i want to be the best version of chico
being that i can be on a day-to-day
basis
and the way that i do that is by
developing a program
that's based on who i am first figuring
out what that means
figure out who you are as a person
embrace it
whatever it may be you might get
scrutinized or criticized
but as long as you're not hurting
yourself or hurting anyone
whatever it is you do is cool so once
you figure out what those things are
embrace that then it becomes easier for
you to find the level of
success for you because you're basing it
off of you and you took that journey of
figuring out who you are as a person
i think a lot of the reasons why
comedians get lost in the sauce when it
comes to this game is because they're
basing their
self-worth off what they believe other
people base
self-worth off but it shouldn't work
like that if
something's not for you it's not for you
but if you're chasing it
even if you accomplish what it is you're
chasing once you accomplish it
it's going to really you up because
when you get there you're going to
realize i did all this work for some
that doesn't even satisfy me
in any capacity so now you you know lost
because you feel like i've i've gotten
there i'm successful now
because i got you know a show or
whatever i'm doing this i'm headlining
i'm making money
but you don't have any inner peace you
don't have any
type of knowledge of who you are so now
that you've accomplished this goal
whatever your goals may be if you're not
basing it off who you are when you get
to that point you don't realize i didn't
wasted
however many years of my life chasing a
goal that wasn't even my goal to
accomplish
you know i mean